grete toon burg arriving at the United
Nations for the climate summit rather
suddenly upstaged by President Trump a
man who doesn't believe human activity
significantly contributes to global
warming
his unexpected presence in the summit
audience perhaps timed to avoid the
searing speech she delivered earlier I
shouldn't be up here I should be back in
school on the other side of the ocean
yet you all come to us young people for
hope how dare you you have stolen my
dreams in my childhood with your empty
words
yet I'm one of the lucky ones people are
suffering people are dying
entire ecosystems are collapsing we are
in the beginning of a mass extinction
and all you can talk about is money and
fairy tales of eternal economic growth
how dare you
that speech reflects the growing public
outrage over a lack of action on climate
change some members of the international
community are using this summit in New
York to match that sense of urgency
nature is angry and we fool ourselves
if we think we can fool nature because
nature always strikes back and around
the world
nature is striking back with fury but
huge hurdles remain for all the focus on
the UN right now on its current path the
world will not meet its targets are set
by the Paris climate agreement so the
challenge is to get all rich developed
nations to do more than they've already
promised and to get those poorer less
developed nations who bear least
responsible 'ti for the climate crisis
in the first place to do more than is
technically their fair share that
includes countries like Costa Rica whose
energy supply is almost 100% renewable
the one thing
most in individuals corporation
governments this will willpower
that's the keeping meaningful collective
action may be hard to come by in this
fractured world but the art of the
possible is what diplomacy is all about
and what the UN is trying to deliver as
the window for action on climate change
grows ever smaller Hannah Thomas Peter
Sky News at the United Nations in New
York